die idee hinter politischer korrektheit
sie war ja nicht komplett böse wenn man
versucht einfach möglichst wenig
menschen zu verletzen oder
herabzuwürdigen auch keine minderheiten
ja aber die leute hatten dass oliver
dass das macht die regelrecht aggressiv
wenn du rücksicht auf minderheiten ist
ja das kommt ja auch nicht gut an
also in grün regierten bundesländern zum
beispiel sollte es textaufgaben in mathe
heben und da ließe
ich habe meine dabei zwei lesben und
transgender mensch 75 bisexuelle und
elton john rabe strenge die steigen in
bückeburg in den gc nach darmstadt
die frage war um wie viel uhr geht im
bordbistro der prosecco aus kann ich da
jemanden anrufen
ich komme nicht drauf
finde es eigentlich nichts zu lachen
aber gut also der dinge ist erst wenn
alle probleme vom richtigen volk gelöst
sind also den heterosexuellen bio
deutschen also dann kann man sich zur
not auch mal und minderheiten kümmern
vorher nicht wissen auch ihr habt die
rechten provoziert absolut absolute und
ist wie eine frau den kurzen rock trägt
ja die muss sich nachher nicht wundern
es so wir haben meinungsfreiheit
eingeschränkt wir haben der deutsche
menschenrecht ein arschloch zu sein
quasi mit füßen getreten und tut mir so
leid da kann ich nur sagen super sorry
leute sorry aber wie geht es denn jetzt
weiter
nein wir müssen uns natürlich ändern ist
ganz klar da beißt die maus kind fragen
ab ist aber schwierig wenn du von heute
auf morgen politisch optimal und korrekt
sein sollst ja aber zum glück gibt es da
jetzt ein homöopathisches medikamente
habe ich mal mitgebracht ganz neuen
markt nennt sich aspirin geheimtipp
jahre beseitigt auch die letzten reste
von respekt und anstand
hier steht nebenwirkungen sind schwindel
blähungen und afd mitgliedschaft hat
soll der 13
liga
wie lange dauert es bis das wird eine
sekunde oder ja obwohl doch jetzt merke
dass ich da mal tut okay kommt sowas
negerkuss troja also ein wenig sieht zum
beispiel so antike jetzt befürchte ja da
hätte ich sie jetzt wahrscheinlich hätte
gesagt der mann ist gewichts technisch
herausgefordert ist ein haarwuchs
benachteiligter gender star innen und
jetzt kann ich einfach sagen guck mal
der welt der fette glatzen [ __ ] die
fresse
[Applaus]